[Music]
let's talk about derek this is a new
show you've been working on uh uh highly
anticipated and it takes place
lava takes place in a nursing home yeah
it's an old people's home um and um it's
about a group of outsiders who uh it's a
show about kindness really because it's
them against the world it's very funny
and it stars me and um carl pilkington
yeah first acting role he's amazing he's
hilarious he's amazing in it yeah and
and and you uh play someone who who
works there yeah um and um
and of course uh
it's about all the problems there you
know the left
they have to worry about um
uh you know threat of closure funding
you know it's the backdrop to being out
you know the other actors are you know
they're really in their 80s and 90s and
so um
uh you know i mean it's so funny because
when you work with the elderly you think
of simple things they can't get up and
downstairs by themselves so you have to
you know uh um
everyone's got flu you've got you
haven't given flu you know um so no
french kissing um
that's what you're known for on set
isn't it exactly yeah yeah you're always
very tempted to french kiss the elderly
also and also if if one of them died and
i'd already filmed some bits that would
screw continuity
so i had to make sure but they didn't
luckily so
it would just be me and a wig for the
like for the last for the last few
scenes
you're a horrible horrible man we got
away with it we uh they all lived i
think
they're alive when i left i don't know
did you just say did you say they were
alive when i left
[Laughter]
we have a clip here from derek anything
we need to know about this scene i don't
know what the clip is what clip is this
the one on the bus
oh this is me and there's an audience
member
i basically put carl in it and i told
him after we'd filmed it that this
character i wrote for carl but it's
basically carl if he'd never met me and
that really annoyed him right um so this
is this is um me and dougie um he's the
caretaker and i'm a i'm a a nerdy little
autograph hunter and it really winds him
up let's take a look at this clip from
derek
douglas
dougie douglas
sometimes a cat if a dog was chasing the
cat and the cat turns around the dog
stops because it's scared of scratching
his eyes
douglas
douglas
douglas
douglas douglas
douglas
douglas what
what
what i've forgotten answer straight away
i'm trying to drive a buster you're not
the only one on it we've got passengers
if i put this around a lamp do you know
what i'll get into
just just calm down we can have a chat
when we get back we've got nothing to do
all afternoon you know what it's like
it's like having a wasp in the car you
know when you're driving you've got this
extra stress going on that's what it's
like
[Applause]